I can be very flirtatious nope it's the
last season that the show coming out I'm
really bummed about it but why was this
the right time for view tag you know I
think that time that's the writers feel
really confident that they can have the
adequate freedom to just go for it like
a no regrets thing you don't have to
hold anything back when you know that it
can come to a completion and so that's
you know I think that's what we're all
really looking forward to Amy's pregnant
are you gonna be wearing a belly what's
what's the plan fans are really excited
to like see something happen between Amy
and Dan how did that feel were you as
surprised when you saw in the script
like Oh things went down I went very
surprised they didn't warn us um and I
don't I still I'm kind of a little like
what the yeah but you know they it's
been since day one but Dan and Amy are
are a nice carrots for the off you
birthday destiny no there's certainly
there's certainly you're certainly
kindred spirits so why it was this the
right time pretend it seems like in the
writers room this year they sort of
stumbled into kind of a perfect way to
take the show and it turned into what
they thought would be a great final
season so when they started writing they
had no intention of ending the show and
then two months in it's sort of raised
its creative head and I think they're
all very proud of what they came up with
for our final season really so would you
guys kind of known that it was going to
be ending no no one knew really until
the writers got in the room and spent a
couple months figuring out what's next
and what do you want to see happen for
Mike and for the other characters I've
always wanted vite to go to space and
have us be the people to colonize the
next planet so I'm hoping that I don't I
don't know but I'm hoping that's what
happens at the casual order let's give
the people what they want
[Music]
you